hello reject nation Greg Alba here and
I'm John so today we're gonna watch the
series premiere episode for a show I'm
greatly looking forward to called Black
Lightning
it is 10:40 p.m. right now so we can
only show 10 minutes of this reaction on
YouTube guidelines but the full reaction
will be up on our patreon so become a
patron eject today people doing plenty
of TV shows now anyway John are you
ready I'm excited to see the show really
excited amazing things about this yes
this is your first CW show
my name is Jefferson
[Music]
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
he's gonna help that girl
[Music]
give the nicer dicks
oh the hell with you [ __ ]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dude don't mess with the man's daughter
[Music]
nice
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
again
oh he's gonna do some crazy [ __ ] oh
don't do that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh no Jack White
[Music]
[Music]
eyes
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
like letting go
f you up mother
I just saved one but the musicals
transition Oh what is that those guys oh
I guess this imagine nobody quit the
seahorse motels any good
[Music]
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
nice
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my question is PTSD
so she has powers too right
there we go Oh
[Music]
do it cause he's got a lot hotter oh
dang oh nice yeah alright nice alright
it was pretty rad okay okay I liked it I
liked it it feels very different than
all the other CW DC TV shows I know this
isn't 100% linked to the arrow verse at
least not yet just doing their own thing
it felt very different from what I've
walked through the room and seen you I I
was kind of thrown off by how immediate
it was like from the very beginning I
thought there'd be some like setup and
settling into his lifestyle you know
stings started coming up or you start
seeing him getting a calling to be Black
Lightning but the show starts off with
this was the night he became Lachlan
yeah so it all started right here yeah
because it sets you up in the world like
hey we don't got time for that this
world is just messed up right now we'll
learn about some of that later yeah
right now this is the crucial night it
didn't do like show you a teaser and
then go back to the past like it just
kept going from there on it so I guess
the way they executed the plot threw me
for a loop but I liked it at the same
time because it has its format stand out
differently than the other CW shows by
doing it that way and I like the whole
concept of this debate of should he
become black lightning again or not
because as an audience you're like yeah
you should become why clearly he should
you know it's understandable why he was
giving it up I love that short live
debate II have a
gam B James remar why he's like you know
what the problem with being black
lightning is there's no bottom I think
you know yeah never ends and they
they're really breaking down every major
characters philosophy at least which is
you know awesome I love that this
episode kind of shows all sides of these
escalating actuations as they're setting
in because not only are you watching
black lightning you know have his reor
ajuns story but you're also getting to
know the daughter's lives in the
situation that's gonna become the MEAC
threat of the episode over time like I
thought as a pilot this was a really
really well structured like gracefully
done pilot that's both like fun and
thrilling
but also serious and gripping and like
borrowing directly from studies gritty -
yes freising lee like more gritty than i
actually anticipated it to be clearly
acknowledging issues that are in the
cultural conversation right now and yeah
shying away like violence in schools of
police violence like sorts of stuff race
violence yeah what even like those
little touches like that guy on CNN
talking about when there's other
superheroes it was great as a great
touch this show already feels like it's
on its strike world and that's really
cool cuz a lot of you know there are a
lot of shows where you got to watch
three or four episodes before the stride
really kicks in and before they really
find the rhythm but I feel like with
this show everything pretty much had its
rhythm everything looked great there's
some great shots because it's so
immediate like it just has this instant
hook of we're gonna throw you into the
world the 100 gang what's going on in
that there was a former vigilante named
Black Lightning and they set it up it's
really fast-paced but they set it up
pretty well I love all that history I
find that more compelling instead of
this being like brand-new for this
person's life it's this calling it's
kind of like a John wick which gives a
more personal touch immediately to the
villain that we didn't spend too much
time with the Tobias character who's
gonna tease us to it but it already
makes the bill and feel more personally
involved because of what he's saying at
the end - la la this felt kind of on par
with like a daredevil to me were like
you're really seeing what things are
like in the city yeah I know you're
seeing how this affects a lot of people
because that's part of what makes it so
compelling as that's how these kinds of
issues are is they're all parts of
ripples in in in Everett oh yeah and I
love that you kind of only get a glimpse
of Tobias in this episode and that
glimpse leaves in it that was great
scary like that character like you meet
him in a very nasty situation and then
when Jeff goes to talk to him for a
minute there you're like seems like a
kind of charming reason yeah oh wait no
no I love it I had that with his kid
where he's like really schooling him in
his own fashion you teach them well I'm
your way and I'll teach them my way
because this is this whole episode was
like a battle of philosophies even with
his own family and the family is great
they feel like a real family like
sisters feel like actual sisters to me
when they're interacting with each other
very effective and the chemistry has
with his ex-wife
Wow that was like oh yeah I already want
them to get together electric also
occurred to the cast because this is
such an immediate episode I feel like
the writing complements everything
because it's to the point but also
there's a lot of character stuff and
even the exposition it all feels like
they bothered to justify how it's a part
of the conversation and the actors man
are all pretty terrific and I'm excited
to see James remar doing this role
that's a cool role for him to be doing
at the heart of but yeah there's the
part of the heart he seems to be you
know really in about the spirit of what
it's for I like the portrayal of the
races here they're primarily white and
black but it's like there's some good
white guys are some bad white guys
there's some good black guys or some bad
black guys and there's gray all over
this gray all over the place that was
good cuz you got the part of the whole
part where the chief is like hey you
know two good officers in you're like
well yeah and then you even that moment
even caused me to wonder well was it
should he have used his powers right
here is like should you've done it
you're like that is a character yes it's
a bit gray at least he did blow up their
car flourishes like that that are all
about which side of the perspective you
get to see I love the way they're
writing this is the action there was
really cool I like the combination of
him just doing actual hand-to-hand
martial arts and it has that effect of
lightening shock in his punches and it
occasionally knows when to use the
actual lightning bolts yeah it sets you
up for a great season I want to see this
all take place I want to explore the
villains I feel like we'll get to know
the 100 game even better especially
Tobias this seems like it's gonna be a
great serial show to be on board with it
doesn't feel like it's gonna be as
villain of the week as a lot of the
other CW shows are I hope no I mean it's
it seems like it's in a position to do
stop very specific tale yeah it can draw
from a lot that's going on in our world
right now which is arguably the best use
for this medium it's fun and enjoyable
but it's also kind of shedding light on
the other thing and I mean I don't know
about you but I love the soundtrack
hated it yeah every second no it's a
wide variety especially with the way
they edited it especially stood out when
they have the Jack White song when what
he's standing at the hook motel and it
goes into the actual hotel room and it's
a change of music for a different vibe
and like Lala's going he's gonna kill
them let it and then it cuts right back
no idea this is black lightnings world
yeah I like that approach again it's
like the music is cool but I also like
the way it complements cut every singer
make every yeah yeah cuz each scene has
its own integrity in its own flavor
what's happening in here is necessary
exactly alright guys we're gonna be
watching black lightning we can only
show 10 minutes on YouTube full reaction
on patreon so go become a patronage act
today in the meantime you can subscribe
to the real rejects click that
notification bell get notified every
time a video of ours is up